yeah if we had a training video to show
you what not to do as a police officer
and what not to do as respondent
officers this will probably be a perfect
example Dave Rubin and this is the Rubin
report reminder everybody to subscribe
to our YouTube channel and click that
notification bell and joining me today
is an ex-police officer and co-founder
of the blegh zit movement Brandon Tatum
welcome back to the Rubin report how you
doing Dave man good to see you again
I'm good I'm good thanks for joining us
I know this is last-minute and you are
stretched a million ways because
everything going on right now so for the
people that don't know you we're gonna
link to our original interview down
below but can you just do like a couple
minute Brandon Tatum 101 about your
childhood and what got you into policing
and then out of policing and then we're
gonna obviously talk about everything
going on right now okay cool I grew up
in Fort Worth Texas I grew up in a split
home I'm and daddy wedding together and
they didn't even know their parents or
at least their their fathers and so
people would project that I would have a
certain outcome in life maybe I wouldn't
be successful but see that wasn't true
God had a plan for me even though my
parents were fostering me to be the best
that they could do I ended up getting
arrested at eight years over smoking
marijuana in a vacant house and my dad
had a very stern and strong conversation
with me after that incident which led me
to one of get into sports and want to do
the right thing
from that point moving forward
all-american football player I played
college football at the University of
Arizona and after the NFL didn't work
out for me I needed a job I needed a
career I never thought about being a
police officer a day in my life and I
signed up because I needed some money I
needed a good career and I did a
ride-along with the police department
cuz I had to figure out what the heck am
I gonna actually do if they hire me and
after I did a ride-along it just blew me
away
I was inspired for the first time in my
life I saw a hero and officer Shawn
Payne who took me on that ride-along I
started to get into politics later in my
career as a police officer and
just led me to where I meant now now I'm
doing things on my own on my own
business working with Ken as long as we
co-founded blix it and now I'm on Dave
Rubin for the second time can you talk a
little bit about how when you were a
police officer that you sort of knew how
to speak the language of the people in
these communities so you kind of were a
bridge between the communities that were
being policed or that needed the
policing the most and the actual police
officers because I think that'll
probably be a good segue to get us to
everything else happening right now
yeah cuz I grew up with with a lot of
exposure to a lot of things that I dealt
with as a police officer in these
communities you know I didn't grow up in
a peachy household you know my mom and
dad was separated like I said before and
my stepdad was a gang banger and he used
to use drugs and he ended up dying from
a heroin overdose so some of the
problems that we dealt with in the inner
city
I was exposed to him myself and so I
could speak to individuals and for some
reason and I don't know why cuz you're
still gonna go to jail the same way but
because I was black a lot of
african-american people in the
communities that I Patrol they saw I
guess a connection with me and so I was
able to be sort of the liaison or you
know a lack of better turns the black
person whispered they used to always get
me to come to the scene to talk and to
calm down individuals and like I said
because I've been there done that I was
able to communicate effectively okay so
as I said earlier we're gonna link down
to there to the other interview that we
did so people can get more of your story
but let's jump into the current
situation so first off let's talk about
the incident itself and and the video
that now everybody has seen and has
millions and millions and millions of
views what happened to George Floyd from
your outsider perspective just knowing
the amount that we can know from from
video what we're what went wrong
did anything go right what were the
other officers doing what are you
supposed to do as an officer in a
situation like that just just lay it all
out yeah if we had a training video to
show you what not to do as a police
officer and what not to do as responding
officers this would probably be a
perfect example I don't see or I don't
have any information
of what happened before this gentleman
ended up on the ground but what I can't
tell you as a police officer a former
police officer is that it's unacceptable
to have your knee on a man's neck for I
don't know eight nine minutes it there's
no reason he's handcuffed
he's on the ground you have leverage
over him and he's complaining of having
medical issues people are recording you
and you still remain in a position that
seems to be putting this gentleman at a
at a life and death situation so as a
former police officer any rational
person you should be rendering aid you
should back out for the guy and there
was a concept that I said in a video
that I made on my youtube channel is a
concept of excited delirium and a lot of
people never heard of the concept of
excitedly real maybe if you're not in
law enforcement you probably would never
hear of it but excited the lyrium is a
theory that when people are hyped up on
drugs those uppers like PCP
methamphetamine it gets your heart rate
up get your adrenaline rushing and what
happens you become a superhuman and then
your body begin to crash so you go down
a path of crashing kind of like if you
drink sugar and you get tired of sleepy
afterwards but this crash it goes and it
continues until you die and we're
trained as police officers to be able to
observe that and some of what mr. George
Floyd was experiencing seemed to be a
level of excited delirium so when when a
guy is going down like that a police
officer back off render aid roll him on
his side make sure he can breathe
because he could be hyperventilating he
could be having some distress that may
not be a direct connection which are
knee on his neck and you should know
that as a police officer so it seems to
me that part of the reaction to this one
that is totally justified is that the
officer had his hand in his pocket
almost as if I'm not even trying here I
can just do whatever I want what do you
think and I know you can't read their
minds but the other three officers that
are standing there what do you think is
going on in their minds that as they're
watching this I mean put you know where
everyone's laying blame where it should
be laying at the officer who did this
but what about the other guys because
that gets too
people start talking about the culture
of policing yeah I don't think it's so
much of a cultural response it's of a
human nature you know the other officers
I'm assuming are waiting for the next
officer to say something and nobody ever
says anything and then I believe that
that officer seems to be somewhat of the
lead officer on the case he's the most I
guess it could be the most experienced
he's the most dominant and so I'm
assuming and I don't know if this is
what they were thinking but I've seen
this happen before is once operational
momentum gets underway there are
officers who are assuming and hoping to
God that the officer would his knee on
the guys neck is acting in good faith
and it's not gonna kill the guy and get
everybody fired so there's a little bit
of expecting the officers to all do
their own job and expecting an officer
who who is coming across as the leader
to not kill a man in cold blood so I
think that there's a little bit of
cowardice that goes on and people in
general and I see some of that could
have probably spilled over to this law
enforcement experience with George Floyd
when you see that video do you
immediately view it through a racial
lens you know the way the media pushes
everything on us is that we have to see
this as white officer you know black man
that we have to view it purely through
that and I'm not saying we shouldn't see
it through that lens but that there are
probably several lenses that we should
see these things do when you see that
how much of your reaction to it is just
viewed sewers through the racial prism
alone well Dave I never look at things
racially unless I have a reason to so
when I looked at this video I see what I
believe to be cop or police misconduct
and I see a man struggling for his life
or potentially having a medical issue
with no officers rendering aid race
never entered into my mind not one time
and unless I saw that the officer was a
clan's member or he came out of City
hate black people or something of that
nature that would have instigated me to
have that thought process I don't even
go down that road because it's pointless
is counterproductive and
all it does is create division and we
can never get to a solution anywhere
anyhow because some of the offices I
think it was only one out said it was
white and that was the officer that was
using for us but the other other
officers are going to be held
accountable as well they all got fired
and they were up other races so to
project and make it as this is a black
and white racial tension thing is
disingenuous and it's hurtful to the
narrative and it's hurtful to us
actually getting justice where justice
is deserved yeah so okay so since I
think everyone watching this probably
agrees with that I mean any sensible
person we want justice to be served
obviously they've been taken into
custody and hopefully the system will
deal with them appropriately so we have
to shift to now what's becoming the the
bigger story here so as the guy that
co-founded blends it with Candis Owens
it seems to me that you guys have made
just absolutely staggering amounts of
traction in terms of waking up black
people to you don't have to be a
Democrat which is just a simple fact of
the world your skin color of course
should not dictate what political party
you are so first let me just start let's
let's just start with that how is that
just connected to all of this the the
narrative that we're seeing right now
that America is racist and that policing
is racist and it's systemic and that our
founding is racist how is all of that
stuff connected to why you guys wanted
to start blogs it yeah because when you
think about it for what it is it's like
we are outraged we are burning built
burning down communities protesting and
rioting days in day in and day out for
what and what I have observed that can
is alike well we have observes that we
have been brainwashed into thinking what
our emotions are not thinking with facts
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlists
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell